the last really essential or salient
piece for understanding the mechanics of
how bitcoins work is what we call the
the transaction block chain so if you
recall in the previous videos we had a
motivating example of a user Alice who
wanted to let's say send some number of
bitcoins to another user Bob in the
system and what Alice had to do to
initiate that transaction was to
construct a transaction a record of
sorts that contained information about
the transaction and that was signed with
Alice's signing key and that actually
contained Alice's public verification
key involved public verification key as
well okay and that transaction
information was basically broadcast out
as we as we mentioned to the entire
Bitcoin ecosystem to all the nodes on
the Bitcoin peer-to-peer network now the
various nodes in the Bitcoin ecosystem
what we're going to sit there they're
going to receive information about this
transaction but they're also going to be
getting information about a lot of other
transactions that are taking place
around the same time okay and what these
notes are going to start doing is
they're going to work on incorporating
this transaction record into really a
ledger of all transactions that have
ever taken place in the Bitcoin system
and so what happens is that each node
basically starts off by taking all of
the previously unincorporated
transactions that they've ever received
so there can be all these transactions
out there that have kind of happened
within a given time window and so
there's all these Bitcoin transactions
kind of floating around and these nodes
these Bitcoin miners are as they're
called are going to receive information
about all these different transactions
and they're going to start working on
incorporating those transactions okay
now their first goal is to collate these
transactions okay into what's known as a
transaction block so if you recall our
ledger analogy a single Bitcoin
transaction essentially corresponds to a
proposed entry in a ledger in that
capacity a transaction block would
basically correspond to an entire page
in a ledger where you have multiple
transactions that are listed in that
page of the ledger and the goal the
Bitcoin miners goal is
essentially to take that that page and
get it added to the global ledger but
the global comprehensive ledger book all
right now to engage in this sort of work
what these nose will basically do is
they'll first take all the transactions
that have been broadcast on let's say
these four transactions have been
broadcast out okay and they're going to
basically hash these transactions in
pairs okay and basically in a tree-like
structure so they'll they'll take these
two transactions and they'll apply a
cryptographic hash function to those
details and they'll get a corresponding
digest they'll do the same for these two
and then they'll take these two digests
and hash them to get a single digest
value and this digest effectively
encodes all of the transactions that
were previously unincorporated and that
were received by these individual nodes
all right and then this digest is
basically going to be combined it's
going to be combined with the hash of
the transaction block that was
previously accepted by the network so
you can imagine that there is the
network will have a series of
transaction blocks that were previously
accepted and in fact every transaction
block as I mentioned just now
incorporates the previous transaction
block so this transaction block will
incorporate the one that was used just
before it and this transactional block
will incorporate the one that was used
just for it and it's going to go on
literally until the beginning of Bitcoin
times this is really where the Bitcoin
the beginning of time for the Bitcoin
system okay this is just a time time
equals zero for Bitcoin okay and they're
going to take this last block and
they're going to essentially now take
this last block and combine it with with
this most recent block and so if you
imagine that you have now not just an
individual block but because each
individual block incorporates the block
before it we're not dealing anymore with
an isolated or distinct block of
transactions but rather with a chain of
blocks that starts literally at the
beginning of the entire Bitcoin system
all right now when you do all this
combination at the end of the day you're
going to do some cryptographic hashing
and you basically will end up with a
sequence of numbers okay and this
sequence of numbers will be derived by
incorporating all these blocks together
you'll get a sequence of numbers
and what we're going to basically do is
take the sequence of numbers and convert
that sequence of numbers into a
challenge in a proof-of-work protocol
okay now I did a separate video on
proof-of-work protocols I would
encourage you to watch that if you want
to get a better sense for how they work
but the short of it is that what the
Bitcoin mining node has to do at this
point is he'll take the Bitcoin he'll
take the the challenge and you'll have
to come up with a separate sequence of
numbers which we typically term the
proof or the proof of work and this
proof of work has to have a very
specific mathematical property with that
property entails is that if you take the
the challenge numbers and you take these
proof numbers and you concatenate them
together and you make them the input to
a cryptographic hash function okay the
resulting output has to have a large
prefix of zeros okay
and that isn't have to be all zeros but
a large portion of the the beginning the
prefix has to be all zeros okay and if
you think about it for a moment given
the cryptographic hash functions given
that their output tends to look fairly
random it's unlikely that in any given
instance you are going to see a proof a
proposed proof that provides you with a
large string of zeros at the beginning
and so what the Bitcoin miner will have
to do is on average he let's try many
possible choices for these proof numbers
until he finally gets lucky and he
stumbles upon one that has this kind of
offbeat or strange statistical property
okay and the actual difficulty of
finding these proof numbers as you can
tell is dependent on exactly how many
leading zeros are required okay the more
leading zeros you require in this in
this proof the the longer it takes to
actually solve the problem longer it
takes to actually come up with a proof
that works with respect to a given
challenge the fewer zeros that you
require the less time it will take now
the exact number of bits of zero bits
required in the Bitcoin protocol
actually does change over time it gets
calibrated and it's designed so don't on
average the average time taken across
the whole system should be about about
ten minutes okay so you wanted to take
about ten minutes
for at least one node to come up with a
valid proof but keep in mind that a lot
of nodes are working on this proof
concurrently all right now once this
proof of work is found let's say that
the proof of work is eventually found
the Bitcoin miner will announce the
results to the overall peer-to-peer
networks who's going to take this proof
and really all to challenge it and so on
and he's going to announce it to all the
other nodes and they're not going to see
that hey there's this proof out there
somebody found it let's drop the other
stuff we're doing and we're going to now
start to work and build on top of this
new proof a number this new proof and
this new challenge these all incorporate
all the previous transaction blocks you
really what they're starting to do is
they're starting to work off of a new
updated transaction block chain okay and
they're going to incorporate any new
unincorperated transactions into that
new transaction block chain now there
are a couple of points I want to make
here so first of all is part of
constructing these transaction blocks
and really as part of incorporating them
into a transaction block chain Bitcoin
miners are actually allowed one little
special special treat they are allowed
to include in that transaction block a
special node for themselves and this
node will basically be a little reward
that they can get and let me let me use
the kind of a greenish color for that
reward so they can take the first the
first block the first transaction item
okay the first transaction record and
they can put in that transaction record
they can assign a reward to themselves
okay now the amount of that reward will
change over time okay but I do want to
point out that what this this
transaction is typically called is it's
called a coin base a coinbase
transaction or a a generation
transaction this is how new coins get
included in the Bitcoin system so
whenever a miner succeeds in coming up
with a a proof as part of that he leaves
he'll have been allowed to come up with
his own transaction to reward himself a
special reward for expending the effort
necessary to come up with this proof and
for doing all this work associated with
adding a new transaction block to the
existing transit
and blockchain for Bitcoin alright and I
think that's reasonable after all these
nodes are using a lot of computational
power to come up with these these proofs
and that if they're using computational
power that must mean that somewhere
along the line somebody is spending
money on electricity and so on now I
also want to point out that in addition
to this this coin base award the nodes
who are doing the Bitcoin money the ones
succeed also get to collect the
transaction fees that were specified in
the transaction records if you recall on
a person issuing a transaction in
Bitcoin can allocate or set aside a
certain amount of money maybe it could
be a Bitcoin or a fractional Bitcoin for
the node who succeeds in coming up and
coming up with the actual proof of work
and effectively the node that succeeds
in being able to add that transaction to
the overall Bitcoin transaction block
chain and so that node that does the
work that succeeds gets a reward of a
transaction fee now this this could
actually become quite large because the
node will not only get the transaction
table for one transaction it'll get the
transaction fee for all the transactions
that appeared in the current block
that's going to get the aggregate over
all these different these different
transactions all right now the second
point I want to make is that it might be
possible for two nodes to solve the
proof of work independently of each
other and somehow they may both end up
trying to add to that existing chain in
some way so you may get some weird chain
forking happening right that happens the
peers in the Bitcoin network will
basically break a tie by sticking with
the longest chain and by longest I don't
mean the one that has maybe the most
transactions in it I really mean the one
that has the highest aggregate
difficulty associated with that
underlying proof-of-work protocol in
each of the the transaction blocks it'll
basically look at the total amount of
effort that was required to generate
that chain but regard to that proof of
work and whichever chain has the most
work associated with it is a chain that
sacrosanct it's a chain that everybody
will accept now you may get some weird
discrepancies because of network latency
issues and so on but the idea is it
after maybe a couple of rounds when
there are ties they'll quickly resolve
themselves as
longest most of the nodes are behaving
honestly and really stick to their
implementation of the protocol all right
now since Bitcoin miners are generating
bitcoins I think there's an interesting
question that comes up here which is you
know how does a big plan money supply
controlled and how is it managed and I'm
going to talk about that concept in a
subsequent video